so what's up guys is prestige here and
we got another episode of Devon survival
for any of you that are you guys manager
some new stuff in front of you that a
nudist this series I plane I'm playing
with the divine RPG mod and I'm just
doing the goods a little thing to say is
that I don't know is that what sorry I'm
present the wrong buttons is that I
don't really record everything so it's
not a completely usual survival thing so
yeah I got some empowered me I spent a
lot of time in drab like I get sick
strat 7 driver like blocks five chunks
three gems and ten fragments and
actually I realized that I'm gonna stop
making these and I'm making these which
is made out of seven of these and this
is for armor and once you have a full
set of dry white armor you get four
drops so you get like more of this /
breaking blocks which is a lot better I
also spent some time ahsoka and the
nether and yeah I just do something
these diamonds like really so actually i
just got a protection three-inch him and
also i got sharpness three knocked back
to on that thing that's nice that I got
some awesome channels from a bow
actually can i enchant this nope that
can't be enchanted can be enchanted like
that I'll protection wouldn't work there
but uh no I could probably use on
breakings I've gotten like a few one
breakings I'm breaking too when braking
to be I have a efficiency for that'll be
good for a tool i guess whenever I don't
use this tool I also i could upgrade
this but one thing i want to do is I was
thinking if I have protection to on all
of this but I have nothing on here but I
protection three would it be more worth
it to do it on my chest or my boot size
again I'm just going to do it in the
boots and I'm pretty sure we do that
because I'm will just think you'll be
more effective to have it since it'll
just the protection too will just
disappear on that so let's do a quick
check for how many levels it's going to
be five okay we can get five levels
pretty fast so I'm going to go at five
levels and we're also
gonna try finding an end now I got a
bunch of ender pearls and I got I killed
uh and I got in and I got blaze rods
from the nether Wow gosh usually these
guys don't attack you maybe want to
pissed off last night's know that
attacking last night I take one of them
and the usual run away that killed a
clue of those guys as well but I get so
I have a lot of eyes of Enders so we can
at least look for a stronghold we can
make some progress like we can start
journey towards that we might not find
it but hopefully we will just trying to
get five levels of XP up nice if we
found a crab since a crab would probably
get me write it there did ya see this
divine sword is just wrecking wrecking
like a bow so you did pee somewhere and
kill epic slime slime I comfor goods
everything I picked up that XP what the
heck out out for the count uh yeah I
don't really care about snob also up
crap in the water ah slimes can't swim
so quit that XP look take it goes super
super bright all right now let's go back
up and let's hit you this way I'm going
to drown and Boop do do okay you know I
I can't see anything down there so I'll
just go kill some deals like that zambie
Sam Bambi so yeah we're just going to be
chillin I really want to get to the end
since once i get to n then they can
extrapolate to get a lot of other stuff
like I can get the a certain portal I
can get um no but I was looking before
and there's nothing a lot of stuff said
don't worry should kill a zombie then we
should be good wow that's on me there we
go
see ya now we're going to go then I'm
going to start our journey let me get
some more torches and saw torch the
entire pathway that we go on so that I
can find my way to and fro toward 40 you
can see I kill every single mom on the
overworld and like a hit with the sword
sharp as 3 i'm so good so sexy oh so
sexy i also got some white mushrooms
that you get that and killing a certain
creature in the ice by own place so
we're going to we need the boots boots
and then boots protection three here we
go are we got a full set of enchanted
and lead to real i might armor all right
now down there throw that in there for
that in there throw that in there so
that and to that that in there and that
in there and we're going to me we have
27 let's bring a stack of these bad boys
and we're also going to want to make
some torches so i want to break
something I sure would I'll just take a
entire tire around half stack so let's
make some sticks and let's make some
torch is well why don't why don't I keep
making torches I dude I've stacks on
stacks I'm killing like a few eyes
alright so yeah I got a bow just cool
and I guess let's go oh and I'm gonna
need those them I vendors so or do we
want to do it in the daytime and two in
dayton sleep up her era got shot yeah I
was a I guilt gotti I was doing a lot of
stuff since when I would get 13 gems i
get like flame one off at love learning
Chapman so I do admit to being a
cheapskate hide minute I was cheapskate
yep
did all that and I ended up getting and
nothing significant so don't worry like
you guys are yelling me for cheating
that's the best I got which is actually
is pretty good i go to a sharpness three
take it to a while I get to sharpen
stories Wow didn't even notice that but
I sure you more legit than not it's just
killing a lot of these mobs gives me a
ton of XP like not these guys you guys
can give me much but like your moms like
crabs and things in dr light and such oh
yeah i gotta i have a yeah this is good
to point out also i'm gonna get a bed
before us on the journey I don't have
any wool do I I don't have one multics
and shares with me but cool thing to
point out I got a mod that lets you keep
your inventory even when you die so that
is awesome and so I die I keep mandatory
oh no it doesn't do much damage we just
freaking whoa that's a cave he just
blows up a landscape feeling like a
creeper you're preventing my progress in
my epic journey bad creeper yeah so
nothing really to fear in the overworld
anymore so let's start this journey
hello Krabs journey go it's not way ok
Oh week I forget I didn't know you could
pick them up oh that makes the journey a
lot easier well I thought they broke
okay shouldn't it get any more of these
we're going to find this Ronald now all
the way I got a light mentor pathway
this will be the great John a the vendor
dragging shouldn't be too big of deal
since he only needs is two hundred nice
200 health which is like nothing
compared to a lot of things all right
throw this and so going that way we're
going to lay in Sri aren't you I called
it can't place it there so I'm going to
do that yeah I don't get any fall damage
so that's cool really is not the most
open path i'm showing doesn't work you
do is I'm above-ground labba yeah so I
really it like I really don't need to
throw them that often and just kind of
run it like ye Ruby shik X for the win
with inefficiency three so i can put
into efficiency porn if i want yeah the
places i just chilled by blaze spawner
and endermen I just kind of had to go
out a night and kill a lot of them ok so
it's gone a little to the right okay
that's good we're getting closer so
let's make sure we pick that bad boy up
and it's cooked every the resource 10
hunger which would be five little hunger
pieces I were in the snow biome
frick frick those things hard that noise
as it drops the white mushrooms I hate
those things they're wicked fast and
they do I damage and snow biomes last
for about 14 years of walking so this
game this should be tons of fun so when
I was reading on the wiki it seems like
snow Oh awesome oh frick frick right no
no all right once I guess
you
you
alright guys i'm back sorry i just got a
call okay let's go let's go big boy
let's go come on come on what the heck I
know I've knocked back a bird step up yo
game there to all there too okay you
know what no we're not doing this I
don't even wanted to you I even want to
deal with y'all sand your snow biome
leave me alone oh why am I getting away
so good it's still chasing me now we're
good all right we can throw another one
of these oh dang i passed it Oh what the
heck you get a little caught up yeah um
this again why I passed a while fail
fail by me what do you do they like
they're like disappearing in the air how
can you guys yeah I really ran past it
dang it okay no uh okay there we go come
on drop anything out time no wats
mushrooms so we're actually we were
really close to it hey broski I just
killed your brother come at me what that
where to go what the heck bro kind of
fight you and you run away ow okay so we
can say we can take to its room so
that's good oh so another one of these
what the okay
there
seems that they're disappearing with the
what the heck man put my oz indigo we
should be close so I think it's coming
there we go it's alright so yeah there's
a catch one drops drops yeah we we
overshot this or I overshot this to the
extreme hook there we go let's throw in
this place it I like ice lake with the
we go oh it's going down oh ok we found
we found it awesome so luckily we have a
rubric acts just like this the heck up
that I know this is where to go and yeah
this will be good oh we don't want to do
that ass so we need a kind of a
staircase yeah this is good this could
do drew 2-2 in staircase it ain't so bad
anymore hey I didn't find any sheep so
we can't I really want to sleep here
because if I die then i can just spawned
that bed
go to check check oh what the why are
you doing that ok we're going to that
damage indicator oh I just heard a
silverfish and that out there there we
go there we go right there here's some
weird noises ok I don't think there's
silver fish can get us from up here ow
nevermind i just broke in the silvers
one though ty m8 hell son hey we got a
lot of them but they can't get me just
break all this this is a really high up
stronghold just break you I want to
break you we're going in wow wow I don't
know Oh little buggers wow that was
close yeah I can still hear the stuff
from up top protection to all protection
three I don't really want that pic Wow
I can't press the button break the door
okay I'm will explore this later on
right now I want to go to the end so lay
all this up and we're going to our few
of them place place place place place I
know bad place place place place place
place place okay now we have that but I
want to go kill some sheep to get a pet
that will keep all my stuff but I don't
have to spoil on somewhere far away so
shap shap shap shap it just need to give
me three okay maybe need bring my own
okay so go down here and we go heat here
and we're gonna make this little room to
chill at boop boop boop boop boop boop
hello yeah just estimating that dirt
okay and physical kabul kabul for the
win ok now we're going to make ourselves
a nice crafting table and put that there
I'm gonna make ourselves a chest so
boo-boo-boo-boo-boo-boo-boop up like
that and be there and throw you and you
and you need my bed bum bum bum bum bum
bum so bad and let's say we're gonna
throw you you
who says we just don't want it crowding
up our inventory I have a free my shears
protection three lava bucket oh right
dang it um I only have 26 arrows so
we're going to want how many leave yeah
I'm just checking since I need a mini
ladders would be like a few stacks but
yeah there's not a few stacks um oh we
can always just tell be our world we get
lugia throw you in there throw you in
there mm keep torches there are you in
there you and or that should be good all
right let's sleep hope you guys are
experienced that so you chill and we're
going to make this an extra-long episode
since we're going to try getting to the
end how this looks disgusting are you
guys ready let's go alright guys I made
to the end and to drag them with them we
spawned really close awesome so uh uh
okay yeah that is one of the new
integration okay back up buddy yeah they
added new mobs into this so there are
new mobs I should have worn a pumpkin
home in here because if i look at them
it's going to be really annoying okay
this is going to be a little bit of an
annoying thing and it appears that one
of them already taxes even without i was
looking at him y african what are you
what the heck what am I looking at oh
those things that a triplet out I felt
bro bro oh gosh oh gosh okay where's my
boat bow wow Oh Frick I don't think I
was prepared enough for this Wow nick is
attacking me back up back Wow don't
think I was prepared for this do not
think so at Sawle thing I greatly
underestimated and heck out what is
attacking me what why I'd even look at
you even look at you bro oh my gosh
stupid explosions oh my gosh this is a
noise crap stop shooting at me you
stupid the triplets pretty sure like I
just killed the person attacking me
yep there he saw my gosh well this might
be a long paddle since when we kill the
Ender Dragon the because that'll he's
just an ongoing nuisance oh my gosh do
these things agri range is about three
miles I can't even see them in the
shooting at me oh my gosh enough enough
with you people gosh they have to give
it that sound effect two can't even
stops like these the bigger towers can
be annoying to try shooting at really
right now would be a time when those
that flying armor would come handy ow
come on come on oh my gosh something's
am i and and no stop up bro do you even
lift this inventory thing is very
helpful oh my gosh we're not getting
shot up by triplets first time ever
there would go perfection shot Oh
shouldn't like boss shouldn't like a
bauce also good ok Enderdragon only
doesn't want to have hearts back out bro
you had nothing on this I don't know
what happened to the ender trickles
while and I miss that shot I guess
something happened to the triplets
because they're not attacking I'm a not
freaking complainant this is one of them
use my ladders on this is worth a lot if
I fall I can get back up with that there
we go um if I had those triplets were
attacking me I would this would not work
at all alright let's see how powerful
this explosion is wow that's it a lot of
damage came up let's go I don't take any
falling damage so i could just jumped
off um i don't even know where the Ender
Dragon is
oh there we go there we go big boys
that's what I like to see how let's make
sure helping their rights oh my gosh
it's like ahkam doc no no not not back
up Bros Bros Bros oh gosh oh come on oh
there we go oh gosh just so annoying
well I obviously taking out a lot of
crystals because he is not entering that
much at all give me the last two rows go
Wow was my last arrow come on till this
glass personal fini time it looks like
it oh come on bro come on come on oh oh
really oh gosh stop it come on I've no
arrows have to fight the energizer so
leisurely take come on bro bro go up I
please that's what's up bro how are you
here Oh Maudie Maudie okay well ill over
burnley buggy to that it's gonna get
back to the end here seriously bro
there's arms are wide open same say
thank you very it's not that is not
human okay so weird I can't ride they're
too scared us come on bro I'm bro yeah
actually going slow to arrange look come
on bro attack me like a look at my do
you see that in verbindung smash you're
just going to know source a shooting
with the thing you can like breaks off
oh I can't even came I'm gonna kill you
so hard little noon come on come on get
down here fighting with man come on come
on let's go fight night how's it not hit
him like right through it oh no no no
dot George George really so yeah I heard
a few stories about how killing a
triplet crashes your game really oh my
gosh that's real what the what oh my
gosh listen to that some BS so the most
annoying thing in the end I'm not
allowed to kill because I die if that I
meant my game shuts down if that I kill
it that's that's a really good thing to
make a nice nice birdie thank you thank
you developers with his game what okay
well he's dead he drops and portals okay
that makes sense so okay you can kill
them just that you have to restart your
game
and then you get their drops yeah makes
sense bro awesome who's pissed off who's
pissed off hit the noise so much so lat
oh gosh hey bro broski let's go go broke
what oh gosh he smacked me to me smack
me again come on bro you got nothing on
this get nothing this house we got more
the annoying people need a nickname for
them or we get good nickname be order
that well they look like three of the
wat watch are these little Watchers so
that's why I under Watchers that's why
they're with it take that's why they are
called where's the dragon no that's why
they're called triplets cuz it triples
but it still annoys crap I don't she'll
call
I'll have a peaceful music playing let's
go yeah why is it looks like he's like a
smile on his face are you enjoying your
death so few good few good amount of
cactus I don't care why there's uses
cactuses but whatever oh let's go oh
wait I'm stuck come on come on oh gosh
come on let me smack your face also I
won't get the egg cuz I'm piston oz I
said come on come on you need a piston
to push the egg because you can't touch
it probably people I don't know let's go
let's go dong Yi booty II we did it we
killed you in Dragon oh we get all the
XP completely forgot about XP oh yes yes
oh we're going to chat all the books all
the books shall get thin chance and
someone's pissed off I'm not surprised
if someone's pissed off cuz everyone's
pissed off I'm gonna check on a watcher
yeah okay so I don't think these guys
teleport just freakin nice yeah
someone teleports pissed off okay see
the egg should be on the top yeah pigs
on the top right there am I gonna kill
enter spiders because those things can
teleport into knowing his head come on
bro what all I can teleport they just
weren't okay good to know there's a lot
less prone to it yeah so I should try
finishing them off oh now all the ender
triplets are freaking white now they're
albinos I'll buy her triplets yeah
messed up the game by coming one okay
now they have no third head okay I'm not
going to touch you nothing i'm going to
touch you well come on come on them kill
you know what that lets go they are stop
stop it oh god I can't hit these people
I'm not allowed to what the Frick what I
with them oh my gosh this is there's
much no sense
oh my gosh now the one I say on fire is
just teleporting forever okay let's just
kill you I need looting on the sword I
need looting bad I'll what's up come on
bro I don't have to switch swords this
spider pissed off all the spiders pissed
off with the screw you spider oh gosh oh
there we go that's what I want sure I
think that's what I wanted out no I lost
74 XP send four levels of experience I
lost the stupid blow up these things
screw this game I must say I might give
them myself those levels back because
that the stock ain't I'm not allowed
kill them no I should get like some
levels back from my dead body and have
someone where word that guy's though is
it over here there's some levels no
there's also a tall they probably blew
it up then they this is also the loot
that yet they probably open up oh that
guy just had just dropped a really cool
loot thing to walnut it's like that I is
made and used for crafting something
I'll just kill some more yeah come on
yeah there we go or watching i'm pretty
sure it's used for something oh thank
you for teleporting like a noob noob
okay no I think I'm going to leave the
nether and on my way back the nether the
end I'm going to I'm gonna kill you
now don't give me anything okay screw
you bro all right no it can you're all
y'all pissed off no screeches screw you
guys oh my gosh I'm not gonna make it
out this way I want to make it out
through the portal but let's go Oh what
up yeah I'm the best I'm the best I'm
probably broke the game and I want to
watch the credits her know skip skip
press the skip button escape okay there
we go yeah I hide the greatest the
greatest ever let's say I want that I
want that don't they won't care for that
need that um sexing that back I'm the
greatest ever man alright guys well I
hope you enjoyed this video it was quite
interesting and see you later he's up oh
wait if you like it they like like
comment rate or subscribe bye